hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer a question
from one of my readers Casey who runs a
company called virtual fit me it's a new
product that she created and it helps
with interactive shopping and she wanted
me to check out her website she's trying
to raise capital find angel investors
and wanted my advice so thanks Casey
let's check out your site so I loaded
here in a new window and my first image
saw you know look at the website not
quite sure what you do is that
interactive shopping so I see you know
women trying to find her you know maybe
some clothing here it says no fit found
and you can customize a little bit about
yourself the different weights heights
or etc you know online shopping made
easy it's great the next thing I read
here is you know note the foregoing
descriptions of specific embodiments of
the present invention have been
presented for purposes of illustration
description and it kind of goes on a
little bit so this is a disclaimer which
is great I mean it's a little wordy but
it's the first thing that I read so i
would definitely move that down put a
little you know asterisks or something
here and have that at the bottom is what
i want to know especially for an event
investors point of view is what do you
do and so this kind of gives me a visual
of it but this does not help so i
definitely want to put something in here
that explains a little bit more about
what you do as I scroll down this is
great here so here you have your
benefits for online retailers increase
online sales decrease returns gain
consumer trust that's great for shoppers
engage in enjoyable shopping experience
try on clothes so this is great this
should be higher up right this should be
no above the full because this is at the
bottom here I may not get down that far
depends if I'm interested at the first
glance or not the other thing is so I'm
assuming you know you make it easy for
people to find clothes that you know
otherwise might be difficult if they're
going to different stores but let's
start a little bit more about your teams
so next we look at is you know
who's your team so if I'm if I'm a
venture capitalist or angel investor and
I get pitched this I even now I'm on a
TV show called the pitch and I get
pitched new business concepts I'll
quickly go check out somebody's website
it's great if you can make this into a
video so i can quickly understand what
it is that you do i understand this um
you know time and effort to make that
happen but how many images is the next
best thing but if you might want to
consider having a video that quickly
explain what is that you do for people
who may not know where to click or what
to read so once I finally understand
what is you do i click on about to learn
more about the team who you guys are
where you come from so we're team of
young professionals bash individuals
take business fashion technology
seriously okay you know you might want
to fix up this paragraph here to make it
line up and then more information about
you but I can't click on anything okay
so especially from an investor's point
of view I want to know who these people
are right at least a little bit of a bio
your background I want to know that the
people who aren't putting money into
have done it before have experience in
the industry you know if you don't have
much experience you can get some
advisors so I see you have this John
adviser here like what's his background
uh what does he advise you on these are
the things that I'm going to be
concerned about as an investor you know
I want you to make sure that the money
that I'm giving you is going to be well
spent and is going to lead to yo me
getting a return on that money so the
team is definitely super important to
making that making that happen anymore
let's look at the the product so this is
great here so you are identifying a
problem and this is how you you
generally want to start things off so
stores generally have the same labels
for clothing sizes small medium large
different stores sizes can vary
oftentimes it's limpiar the case within
the same store so that's great are you
are you know quickly identifying a
problem what's your solution virtual
shop into of consumers to make shopping
easier more convenient to innovative
product that allows individuals to fit
clothes on a virtual image of themselves
to get an exact fit before or by so this
is great so this is this is a better
description of what you do I put
something like this on the home page
because I kind of had to guess at what
you
you just I'm looking at that picture
that you had here they'll done in a new
tab I guess that just from the picture
but it didn't really quickly explain
what it is that you do so something you
know break this down into one or two
sentences and put that here instead of
this description that you know this
disclaimer it doesn't really help you
the next thing that I understand what
you do I would make this out into a
positive case so here it's a no fit
found I would show the person finally
finding the fit and being happy that she
sued will find her bathing suit or
whatever is that she's looking for so
that's maybe a personal thing but the no
fit found you're showing the negative
read probably show positive here or you
show both like somebody going into a
store being really upset they can't find
their size and then somebody using your
system and finding it and it works and
it's fantastic so that's my initial
thoughts make this a little bit easier
you know show show how it works and make
this description better move some of the
benefits higher up move the move this
you know disclaimer further down and
then I beef up the about Us page and
showcase a little bit more about who you
are your background and you know the the
various experience that you have and
show any momentum that you can so is
this being used anywhere it's still in
in beta I'm not quite sure if you have
any retailers using this show that if
you have if you've gotten into any media
show that if you've added more people on
your team show that so all of that would
be would be great so it says here you
know you you have an avatar is gonna be
introduced to retailers it's great if
you know is it this is this is a couple
months ago you know is that has that
been done is that is it working now is
anybody using it those are the kinds of
things that was an investor I want to
see that you have and want them growing
so hopefully that helps that's how I
would break down the business looking at
looking at it as an angel investor point
of view if you guys liked the video
please give it a thumbs up it makes my
day and it makes me want to do more of
these videos for you guys and if you
have any thoughts about this website the
virtual fit me or if you have a question
that you want me to answer feel free to
leave a comment under the video and
I'll definitely check it out so thank
you and we'll see you on the next
episode
you